hello and welcome to the abbott
hematology hit series today
on the art and science of hematology
morphology
i am michelle ashton of labyrinth and
i'll be your moderator
for today's event before we begin
i would like to remind everyone that
this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
please click on the support tab found at
the top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus
offers continuing education credits
please click
on the continuing education credits tab
located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process
to obtain your credits
today our presenter dan pelling will
share his decade-long
expertise in morphology he will start
with the art and science of cellular
scanning
principles and its importance in the
hematology
laboratory then he will tie this
together
for a review of unique patient cases
that will help listeners align automated
hematology results
morphological findings and clinical
diagnosis
dan is the site manager for blood
sciences at st
mary's hospital paddington which is part
of northwest london pathology based
in the uk he has extensive training in
the laboratory
and has multiple degrees and holds a
higher specialist diploma
in hematology and is qualified in
forensic medicine
in his spare time he leads educational
efforts
in the hematology community he teaches
at both undergraduate and postgraduate
level
is the lead tutor for the english
program stream
of the multilingual international
education program
uh image and holds advisory positions
in uk class institute for biomedical
sciences
and the european hematology association
here are today's learning objectives
overview of the mechanics behind slide
making and the importance that
morphology brings to clinical diagnosis
implementation of staining protocols and
consideration factors for your
laboratory
troubles shooting stain quality and
factors to potentially adjust
and crace reviews and morphology
accompanied with results from hematology
here are the required disclosures and
disclaimers for today's
presentation
it is now my pleasure to welcome dan dan
you may now begin your presentation
thank you for the introduction medical
laboratory services are evolving at
a rapid pace and one particular area
where this is happening is the
application of digital technology
and artificial intelligence algorithms
to the morphological classification of
cells
however there will always be a role for
the trained and competent laboratory
scientist
sitting at a microscope reviewing a
blood smear
because at the end of the day we all
know patients results don't always fall
into neat categories and the experienced
eye can often draw conclusions beyond
the ability of technology
and that is why blood fill morphology
and blood film review
will always form the cornerstone of
hematological evaluation
it can help with further testing such as
cytogenetics
molecular genetics fluorescent
in-situ hybridization testing
next generate generation sequence
testing
phytochemistry and and so on and with
the development
of tailored medicine these ancillary
tests play a
very important role in diagnosis and
decision making
about healthcare pathways so we can see
that at the end of the day there are
some key points
about why we review blood films
key amongst all of these is that it
should add value to the results coming
from your automated platform
and that's the point we can see in the
middle of the slide here
we want to confirm the presence or
absence
of flags and other abnormal results
coming from those analyzers
and what is very important when we are
confirming the presence or absence of
those flags or abnormal results
we must review the film in conjunction
with the patient's current status
and clinical history
we can have all of that knowledge in our
heads
but if we're not looking at a good
quality smear
then we're not starting from a good
place we have to know that what we're
looking at
under the microscope is giving us the
correct information
and for that we need to know that we are
looking at
an evenly spread blood film with a
correct area for cell evaluation and
that we're actually looking at the
correct film to start with
because it is very easy sometimes to
pick up a film
look at one set of results on the screen
from a patient
and be looking at blood film from
another patient
so making sure that it's a well-made
smear
with clear labeling and distinguishing
unique
identifiers is paramount
one thing we can do by looking at a film
to know that is good quality smear
is looking at artifacts or the shape of
the cells
for example if the cells appeared all
an ellipticity shape but they're all
pointing with their long axes in the
same direction
it suggests there's probably been a
spreading artifact and one would have to
be cautious
about drawing a conclusion of hereditary
elliptocytosis
for example so now we've got a good
quality smear
is the starting point
this is a diagram that we're all very
familiar with
it's an image of how a blood smear is
made showing
the three key steps placing the blood
drop on the slide
drawing the spreader slide back into
that blood drop and allowing the blood
to
wick or move along the spreader slide
and then advancing the spreader slide
the some automated platforms will do
this
they're not just stainers but they're
slide makers and stainers
and they may use a variation in either
speed or
angle of the spreader slide to take into
account
the viscosity of the blood of course if
we're making blood films manually
we have to adjust the angle ourselves
and this is
where we're looking at the art and
science of morphology
because for many of us have worked in
laboratories for years
we know that learning how to make a good
smear certainly is an art
again this next slide is a diagram
that we're all very familiar with it
shows the different types of smear
qualities that we frequently see in the
laboratories
and some of the causes as well on the
left hand side of the screen we can see
an example of a well-made smear
the edges are parallel and it's quite
long and advances around about a half or
two thirds a slide of
the the length of the slide but we can
see
examples a to h on the right hand side
where the smear
doesn't look very good it's got a jagged
edge
where we might be using a chipped
spreader
lots of parallel lines moving up the
slide where there's probably been
hesitation
as the spreader has been moved forward
or a bit of a point to the slide where
for example the spreader has been moved
too quickly
ride's dna show where we've probably not
put enough blood on the slide to start
with
a blood drop of usually three to five
microliters is sufficient
or where we haven't allowed the blood to
wick along the spreader slide enough
we've got a very
narrow slide up the middle
slide f shows something that
that we see with lypemia or greasy
slides
it's very important to make sure that
our slides are clean
they're not dusty they're not dirty
they're not greasy
slide g shows an example where the
spreader has
been put unevenly onto the slide
and slide h something that frequently
happens
is an example of the type of smear we
see when the blood drop has been allowed
to dry
slightly before the smear has been made
it is important to learn how to make a
smear weld because it is very
easy to fall foul of some of these
abnormalities that we see
so we know that we've got a well-made
smear
then we have to decide are we looking at
the right
part of the blood film once the slide is
stained
we look at it and decide what part of
the film to look at
there are parts of the film that are too
thin to examine
parts that are too thick we have the
feathered edge or the far
leading part of the feathered edge where
cells can be distorted
and then we have this just right zone
one could almost call this the
goldilocks zone of the slide
if we look at a part of the slide where
it's too thin
cells can often appear larger and they
can
lack the central power this can often
lead
to misinterpretation of morphology
if we look at a part of the slide that
is too thick
then the red cells are overlapping and
we can't
really examine the morphology correctly
but if we look at the far right of this
slide we can see
the image that says just right the
goldilocks zone
and that's where the red cells are
ever so slightly touching or maybe ever
so slightly overlapping
but they're not distorting or obscuring
the morphology
if we look at the next slide we can see
that in slightly more detail
and here we have on the left hand side
of the screen
an area of the blood film where the
cells are ever so slightly touching
maybe a small gap between the cells
some cells are slightly overlapping but
we can
see the individual morphology and we can
see the central power
in the cells on the right hand side of
the screen is an area of a slide where
it's too thick to examine and we can see
that the red
cells are slightly overlapping and
obscuring the morphology a little bit
but we would want to
move away from that part of the slide to
an area where
it's slightly thinner an area where
there's a good
monolayer of cells
so we've made our blood smear we know
that it's a good quality blood smear we
know that we're looking in the right
part of the slide to examine cell
morphology
but we need to understand
the stain we need to know if the stain
we're looking at is of good quality as
well
and this is where understanding the
romanovsky stain
really comes into its own romanovsky
stain
is an overarching description of a
number of stains that have been listed
here on the slide
the leishman stain the magrum volgim
sustain
the game sustain on its own right gimsa
or
modified rights stain as well there are
a number of different types that can be
purchased or made
in-house that follow the romanovsky
principle
the romanovsky principle uses two
key components to a stain azure b
and eosin y different manufacturers will
have
slightly different components to their
stain
but those are the common factors that
you will find in
most romanovsky stain that are purchased
the stain principle is based on this
time differential
uptake of components of the cell by the
different
components of the stain
what we need to understand is that this
time
dependent differential uptake of stains
is influenced
by local ph by temperature
and by the ionic charge in the staining
environment
so stating to us in the hematology lab
is usually quite straightforward but
when we look actually
into the processes that are going on
there are a number of components we need
to be aware of
to ensure that we're looking at a good
quality stain
poor quality stain can be very
misleading and at worst it can lead to a
misdiagnosis
so looking at the stain components let's
have a look at azure b
as your b is the basic component of the
stain that binds to the acidic
proteins in the cell nucleus and the
cytoplasm
it is responsible for this polychrome
this
this multitude of colours that we see in
our final slide
and here is the structure of it we don't
really need to understand
in-depth the structure but it's nice to
actually see it here so we can
understand a little bit about
how some of the azure b components
interact with the esn y
components this azure b
is what gives us some of our nice blue
colors and we can see from the next
slide
how that appears
here we have some images of some
immature cells
showing some vivid blue cytoplasm
and some nice purple and mauve nuclei
and each cell in these images shows some
nice clear
nucleolite within the nucleus
so these blue and purples are derived
from
the azure b component of the stain
here we have another example of a
lymphocyte a more mature cell
that has its dark purple nucleus and the
small amount
of blue cytoplasm around the outside
this distinction between the purple and
the blue is what allows us to say
yep the stain is working well
let's have a look at the other main
components of the romanovsky stains the
eosin y
and here we can see the basic chemical
structure
when the azure components and the ears
in components combine
we actually see compounds called as your
ears inactives or as your ears in
substrates the esn y
is the acidic component of the stain
that binds to the basic
cellular components hemoglobin molecules
and certain cytoplasmic granules
and we can see in the next slide
how this appears one of the cells where
this
is most obvious is the eosinophil and we
can see from the three images here
the vivid orange of the eosinophil
granules in the cytoplasm
in fact they're not so much granules as
more as globules they appear like
refractile
little glass beads
when those shine orange then we know
we've got a good stain
working at the right ph
so having looked at a couple of examples
of how the stain
appears in the cells here's a table that
actually shows in more depth
the different components of the cell the
chromatin
the nucleus perinucleochromatin
and the different granules how they
appear
with a good quality stain
remembering that the staining quality
may vary from batch to batch and we will
be looking at this a little bit later
but it's not just about the white cells
and the nuclei and the chromatin
it's also about other cellular
inclusions such as
our odds or how jolly bodies or doley
bodies
they have specific colors as well that
we need to be able to recognize
in order to be able to classify them
so although local procedures will vary
slightly
the majority of romanovsky staining
processes follow a very simple procedure
in which the slides are first prepared
and allowed to dry
at room temperature we do know
that if you dry a slide with excess heat
it can affect cell morphology
however gently blowing obliquely across
a slide
while holding the slide on maybe the
ball of your hand
a little bit of heat comes up from
underside the slide
and you can dry the slide a little bit
more quickly which does help preserve
morphology
slides are then usually fixed they're
stained
they're rinsed in buffer and what is
important
is that step number four that rinsing in
buffer because
it's when the buffer is applied to the
slide
the ionic change occurs which allows
the components of the stain to react
and the color to become vivid
so here's an example of some red cells
saying in the last slide that the ph is
very important
is exemplified with this slide we're
looking at now
on the left hand side of the screen we
can see some nice orange
some pink red cells they've got good
central palla
they're slightly touching ever so
slightly overlapping so we know we're
looking at
nicely stained slides in the right part
of the film
and that color that orange or salmon
pink is because the ph
is about 6.8 which is what we should be
stating our peripheral films at
the image on the right hand side shows
red cells that have been stained in a
slightly more alkaline
buffer that's approximately 7.2
staining red cells at 7.2 is something
that
really we like to do more with malaria
films
because malaria thin films when stained
at 7.2
allow us to see some of the internal
structures more clearly for the
parasites
and some of the intracellular inclusions
as well
such as schiffner's dots in plasmodium
vivax or
maurice clefs in plasmodium falciparum
but we can see this grey-green
appearance
of the red cells on the right-hand side
tell us that the buffer
is too alkaline if we see that we know
that we can go back
and remake our buffer and restain our
slide
that's a very good point to note for
troubleshooting
this slide shows neutrophil staining so
we can see a single neutrophil in the
image
and we can see that the cytoplasm has
nice
discrete granules neutrophil
granules are a very sensitive indicator
of how well your stain is performing
the staining times the staining
temperature and the buffer ph
here we can see an eosinophil that is
nicely stained
with a good purple nucleus three lobes
that we can see
and the vivid orange granules in the
cytoplasm
that combination of colours tells us
that the eozinosim
y component of the stain is working well
and here we see a basophil the basophils
take up preferentially the azure b
component into their granules
and that gives the granules this dark
intense
appearance it is useful to note
that in basophils commonly the granules
overly the nucleus
and indeed they can often obscure it
whereas we don't see this nuclear
obscuring in other granular sites
if we understand those points how the
neutrophil granules stain
how the eosinophil eozinophil and
basophil
granules are stained then we can say
that we're looking
at a good quality smear with a good
quality stain
but let's take a step back and think
about how
we would get to that point let's say
we're implementing a new staining system
what would be the points we would have
to consider
well if we're putting a new process into
place in the laboratory there are a
number of key things to think about
that is how good is the system that
you're looking at
going to be for your service do you
actually
need automated staining or do you need
manual staining
this might be something that's
stipulated in a managed service contract
one has to think about the cost not just
of the appliance but of the reagents the
actual
supply chain for the reagents how easy
it is to use and maintain
the piece of equipment and how easy it
is to train
staff on the equipment but it is also
important to say how does this new
process piece of equipment whatever it
is you're putting in place
compares with previous or existing
systems this is all about compatibility
and compatibility
and it is important to think about
future proofing anything that you put in
place
as well because of the advance of
digital technology and the artificial
intelligence that we spoke about
right at the beginning
when comparing your stain quality from
batch to batch
or when introducing a new system is
often very useful to have a very simple
checklist
of staining components that you want to
look at
and here is a small list of important
points
that you would want to examine on a
stained smear to make sure that the
stain
and the process is working well
you'd want to look at the red cells the
white cells
and the platelets to make sure that
you've covered all
lineages and that all aspects of those
cells
are staining well
it's important to be able to
troubleshoot poor staining when we look
at our slides
and in order to do that we can look at
the color again and here are some
examples
of where the buffer might be too acidic
or the buffer might be too
alkaline or the washing stages may be
too
long or too short or the components of
the stain that you're using
may be too low and we can see the color
differences here under those two
scenarios
with the cells appearing too red on the
left hand side
and the cells looking that gray green
color something that we touched on
in one of the earlier slides
now this slide shows something that
we've all come across from time to time
when we look at a blood film and it
looks very pale and washed out
the nuclear appear appears indistinct
red cells look so brown or maybe
slightly yellow
instead of the orange or salmon pink and
this can
usually be due to insufficient staining
time
or indeed the film's not being fixed for
long enough
or maybe even over washing or using an
old stain that's lost its potency very
important that we know
when our stains were opened and what
their expiry dates are so we don't
overuse the stains
and as i mentioned earlier in one of the
slides the neutrophil granules are
very important they are a really good
indicator of how well your stain is
working
the neutral granules sustained by a
process of
taking up azure b and then es in y
afterwards in a time dependent
differential manner
they're very sensitive to ph and we know
that if we can't see the neutral
granules very well
then we probably have got insufficient
staining time
insufficient buffering time or an
old overused stain
now it's often we see heavy dark
staining granules in a film
in the neutrophils it is important to be
able to distinguish
overstaining from genuine toxic
granulation
so one would often look for other signs
of
toxic changes in neutrophils such as
vacculation
in order to determine whether or not is
its genuine appearance to the granules
the next few slides show some examples
of these
beautiful color changes that we see from
these romanovsky stains
and this is what is appealing to so many
people
who look at blood films we
we see this range of colors these blues
the pinks the purples
and it's very appealing and i've often
thought some slides would
make very good wallpaper or duvet covers
what we're looking at here is a range of
cells going through maturation stages
in the image on the left hand side we
can see a myeloblast
in the middle with its vivid blue
cytoplasm
and its nice purple nucleus and
surrounding that cell we see a range of
mature neutrophils
with different degrees of chromatin
condensation
we can see the purples and the moves
coming out
very well being very distinct from the
neutrophil granulation
just below the myeloblast in that
left-hand image we can see a
pro-myelocyte
with its eccentric nucleus its lower
nuclear cytoplasmic ratio
and the hint of nucleoli in the nucleus
and the granulation in the cytoplasm
along with the nice orange salmon pink
color of the red cells
we can say this is a really good example
of good
quality staining if we move to the right
hand image
not only can we see the difference in
maturation of the chromatin of the
neutrophils
we can also see an eosinophil myelocyte
in the middle of the screen and that
shows its
nice vivid orange granules
a cell that we don't often see
looking at this next side we can see a
range of
neutrophil maturation with
the more open chromatin in the slightly
less mature neutrophils
and the more condensed chromatin in the
slightly more mature neutrophils
we can also see an eosinophil at the top
of the left hand image
looking at the right hand image well the
largest cell there is the promyelocytes
with its eccentric nucleus its nucleated
nucleus the granules in the blue
cytoplasm
and we can also see a nice clear area in
the cytoplasm of that promyelocyte which
is the goldy zone
very important feature for determining
whether or not a cell is a promyelocyte
or not
but as we move around that film we can
see
the myelocytes the metamylocite and the
more mature neutrophil with its more
deep purple condensed chromatin in the
nucleus
a really nice slide that exemplifies the
range of colours that we see
we're now going to move on to some case
reviews
these case reviews aren't for diagnostic
purposes
they're really to exemplify once again
the colors and the art of morphology and
how things link together
moving on to case one this was
a chronic myelomonocytic leukemia that
was beginning to transform
into an acute myelomonocytic leukemia
and we can see a summary of the abnormal
results there
the abnormal results have been
highlighted in bold and red
we can see this had a very high white
count a low hemoglobin
a low platelet count and the analyzer
produced a high immature granulocyte
count of
11.6
what did that actually look like on the
scatter plots coming off the analyzer
because the scatter plots on the
analyzer also provide us with this
additional arm the art of morphology
being able to look at scatter plots and
say
what is this likely to show us on the
blood film
what are we going to be looking for what
are we going to comment on that's going
to add
value to these results and here we can
see some
red cell plots in red and we can see
some platelet scatter plots
in yellow
this next slide shows the white scale
cell scatter plots
neutrophils are represented in yellow
monocytes or the larger cell population
in purple
and the lymphocytes in blue
now that really doesn't tell us that
much from those scatter plots
however when we look at the film this is
what we see
this very high white count 237
looking closely at both images we can
see an absence of platelets
and we can see these large cells
if we go back to the results the
monocytes here were counted as 187
extremely high because it would be
unusual to see a monocyte count greater
than one
but we can see a lot of these cells have
got
open lacy purple chromatin they've got a
moderate to a high
nuclear cytoplasmic ratio and what is
quite nice
in the middle of the image on the right
hand side we can actually see a mitotic
figure where the chromosomes have
stained up with the azure b
components they appear nice and purple
and are beginning to separate out
towards the poles of the cell
a second case study a cml
a chronic myelogenous leukemia or
chronic myeloid leukemia
again we can see a very abnormal white
count
very high 74.8
we can see a raised neutrophil count
raised monocyte count i raise the
azinofield count
and raised immature granulocyte count
we can also see a slightly raised
platelet count and in fact
this was a case that was picked up
almost purely by the rey's platelet
count although
obviously the white cells are abnormal
looking at the red cell plot it's fairly
unremarkable
looking at the white cell plots the
scatter plots
we can see that the yellow the
neutrophil population
is larger than we would expect in a
normal healthy patient
it's more spread out more diffuse
this tells us that there's something
abnormal on this film
and combined with that raised immature
granulocyte count
a film review was ordered and this is
what we saw
a cml with thrombocytosis
in the middle of the film we can see a
large myeloblast
the overall size of the cell is large
the nucleocytoplasmic ratio is
moderate to high it has
a very distinct large nucleolus in the
nucleus
we can see that surrounded by the
slightly darker perinucleochromatin
and the blue cytoplasm the nucleus also
has a slightly oval
rectangular shape to it and the nucleus
seems to go
right up to the edge of the cell as well
all
features which when looked at together
tell you that this
is a myeloblast
the rest of this image shows myeloid
cells at different states of maturation
we can see mature neutrophils that do
appear a little bit abnormal
and we can see a metamylosite probably
late myelocyte
early metamylosite at the bottom
of the film in the middle and
we can see some granulated basophils as
well
with their deep intense blue granules
the range of purples and the pinks
and the blues that we see here are
really good example again
of good quality stains
let's move on to case study three
this was a thrombotic thrombocytopenia
pupura
a condition that has to be acted on
quickly something that we really are
expected
to be able to recognize and act on
very quickly in the laboratory by
informing the clinicians
and we do this generally through the
blood films by noticing key features
and we'll have a look at those in a
minute
the full blood count results were
a little bit unremarkable nothing too
abnormal although there are some
abnormalities there
until we get to the platelet count and
we see the platelet count
is 53 so moderately
reduced it was this
unexpected low platelet count that
actually triggered the film review in
this case
this was the scatter plot the red cell
scatter plot was much more revealing in
this case than it was in the earlier
cases
we can see that the red cells
highlighted by the red part of the
scatter plots
are an abnormal shape
on the left hand side of the screen we
can see two red cell plots one above
each other if we look at the lower one
we can see there seems to be this
a number of red cells actually falling
down from the main population of red
cells
and if we look in the top right hand
scatter plot
we can see that the population is almost
split between
two discrete populations
one that extends right up to the top of
the map
and this bottom central population of
much smaller red cells
well what can these be
well bear that in mind we look at the
white cell scatter plot
we have some fairly normal
maybe slightly enlarged populations of
cells
but they're still nice and discreet and
not particularly overlapping
so it is the red cells here that we want
to look at
and we know from all of our experiences
that the red cell changes that we see on
films can be some of the most dramatic
sometimes
this is what the film looked like we
have a lower power image on the left
hand side
and a higher power image on the right
hand side
looking at the film immediately
highlighted the presence
of a large number of red cell fragments
some of the more traditional triangular
sites that we see
and sometimes we see helmet cells
the cells with the two horns the
keratocytes
part of the fragmentation process
we look at the right hand image and we
can see this in slightly better view
we can see where cells appear to have
been broken up
but as the red cells have been
circulating they've been destroyed
by fibrin that's being deposited in the
vasculature
this is what causes the fragmentation
this particular patient
had 40 percent fragments
a very very high count that had to be
telephoned through
and acted on immediately
the patient did survive
moving on to our final case study case
study four
this was a case study from unusual
thalassemia patient
and here we can see that the white cells
really are quite unremarkable
and the differential is unremarkable
the red cell parameters are what drew
our attention to this case
alone low mean cell volume 62.9
and a very low mean cell hemoglobin 18.1
and then we looked at the platelet count
1826
wow okay so that's quite high definitely
warrants a blood film review
what are we going to see so we looked at
the red cell scatter plots
quite abnormal we actually see the red
of the red cells and the yellow of the
platelets beginning to merge here
there's overlap
and this tells us that actually maybe
the results coming off the analyzer
might not be accurate
we look at the top right hand scatter
plot for the volume of red cells versus
their
hemoglobin concentration and we see that
the population is actually
shifted to the lower part of the map
and slightly towards the left hand side
as well
so clearly there was something very
abnormal going on with the red cells
here
and when we looked at the film this is
what we saw
so again a truly remarkable film
um not very good for the patient but
beautiful from a hematological
morphological point of view
extreme polkilocytosis showing
oval cells elliptoid cells
very long and parallel edged pencil
cells
teardrop cells where they appear to be
budding
we saw microspherocytes we saw
microsites of all different types and
descriptions
so what was going on to produce such
extreme
morphological change well this actually
was a t saudi mutation
now many people might not have heard of
that
but this is a an alpha chain mutation
and it's not a deletion
it's part of a change in the alpha
chains that causes the alpha chains to
be
extended and it is known to cause a much
more extreme
imbalance between the beta chains and
the alpha chains of hemoglobin
leading to this thalassemic presentation
what was so good about this film is the
staining was good
and we saw such a nice appearance of the
red cells
but we were able to link that morphology
with the genetic mutation
and that wrapped up the scientific
aspect of hematology
and the artistic aspect of morphology
and pulled the whole picture together
and told us that yes in fact hematology
is both an art and a science
but these images and the staining and
the color distinctions that we've seen
really bring home to us but morphology
is not just a science it's not just
recognizing
how different cell shapes apply to
different disease states
how different cells stages of maturation
apply to different disease states
it shows us that we need to understand
how our stain is working
and that when we look at these colors we
can tell
in part what's going on with a patient
and we can
make comments on a blood film add value
and hopefully advance patients
healthcare pathway
and that to me is the art and science of
morphology
thank you
thank you dan we appreciate your time
today
and all the valuable information you
have presented for
our audience we will now go ahead and
start the live
q a portion of the webinar as a reminder
for our audience
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
all right dan let's go ahead and start
with your first
question first question says looking at
the last case
quite remarkable red cell morphology
there but perhaps you decided to not
reveal
the true platelet count count to give
the listeners time
to think what it might be can you now
reveal
what the true platelet count actually
was
so yes hello i i can reveal what the
true platelet count was
but uh just to say that these are
questions that sometimes crop up in
hematology quizzes what's the true plate
that counts
in the context of bizarre red cell
morphology
because of that interference what we
found in this case
was the true platelet count was 171.
not twenty 1826.
so a a huge difference
in the platelet counts
great thank you so much okay let's go
ahead and move on to our next
question what is the exact angle
required
to make a good smear
well of course the exact angle to make a
good smear
does depend upon the hematocrit
or the pax cell volume of the blood that
you're using to make the smear
if you have a normal healthy patient
whose hematocrit or pcv is between about
0.4
and 0.45 or between 40 to 45
then it's usually about 30 degrees the
angle that the spreader makes with the
slide
if the patient's hematocrit is slightly
lower so they're more anemic
then one would want to increase that
angle and hold the spreader slide
slightly more upright maybe at 40 45
degrees
that means that you're not pushing the
blood all the way to the end of the
slide
if the patient's hematocrit is slightly
higher maybe
0.5 0.55 or 55 to 60 percent
then you would want to decrease the
angle and hold the spreader slide
a little bit lower down maybe at about
20 degrees or so
and that allows that thicker blood to
make a proper
decent length slide
now how long would you say a slide can
stay unstained
before it is too compromised to seem
again that really depends on the
environment that you're keeping that
unstained
slide in are you keeping them fixed but
unstained
or smeared and not fixed and not stained
i would say the smaller smallest period
of time possible
really but if you're going to try and
store
unstained films then i would try to fix
them at least
first and then certainly in my
experience
we've kept unstained slides up to about
three to six
months sometimes and the morphology has
been perfectly acceptable when we've
gone back
to stain them if they're unfixed
then yes i probably wouldn't keep them
that long
probably up to about three months but
really it does depend upon the
environment
i would try to keep them away from light
and away from any sources of dust
or other contamination
great thank you okay this next user
would like to know what usually
causes pale pink stains
if you have a pale pink stain then
um you can be looking at insufficient
buffering time so you might want to
increase the amount of
time that the slide is exposed to buffer
in that final step
of the romanovsky stain your staining
principles
it could also be that you have a
slightly
older stain so if you have a low
throughput of slides in your particular
laboratory
then you may not use up your stain as
quickly as other labs that have a higher
throughput
which means your stain is open and
exposed to the air
for a little bit longer which means it
can lose some of its potency as some of
those components
oxidize even in supposedly sealed
systems
this can happen so i would first look at
your expiry time
how long the stain has been open and in
use
and maybe renew the stain open a new
batch for example
or maybe slightly increase your
buffering time because remember it's
when that
buffer is added in the final few
final stage of the staining process that
the color
and the reactions are taken to their
final steps
now what can i do if i discover low
count during differential
if one discovers a low count during a
differential
well when we perform um
if we're talking about manual
differentials usually when we perform a
manual differential
one would do that on a 100 cells 100
white cell count
if the count is particularly low
usually less than about 1 or
less than about 0.5 one can reduce the
number of
cells that you're counting to maybe 50
or even 25 sometimes
and then multiply up by a factor of
four if you're counting 25 cells or two
if you're counting 50 cells
to get your final percentage for your
different manual differential
that that of sometimes is easier said
than done
what one can do to avoid statistical
bias for particularly low counts
is make descriptive comments on the type
of white cells that you have seen
for example post bone marrow transplant
patients
may have extremely low white counts
0.1.2
performing a differential on those could
be misleading sometimes
what could be more useful to the
clinicians is describing the types of
cells you've seen
scanty a few moderate numbers of
neutrophils or lymphocytes for example
and whether or not their morphology is
normal or abnormal
thank you dan all right let's go ahead
and move on to our next
question when preparing the smear
how long should the slide be allowed
to air dry and does long hours of drying
for example overnight have an effect on
the morphology of
cells
okay so to answer the second part of
that question
first yes prolonged drying overnight
can alter the morphology of the red
cells
the cells can begin to show signs of
creation
or shrinkage even when they have been
spread
but not fixed really the ideal approach
to
drying and then beginning to fix and
stain your slides
means that that first step of drying
should it should really be done as
quickly as possible but not in a forced
way
as we said in the presentation applying
excessive heat can really distort
cell morphology but gentle heat
allowing the slides maybe to dry over
two to three minutes
is usually acceptable and it shows no
loss of morphology usually the good
morphology
is preserved
great thank you okay this next one's a
really great
great question as technology advances
over the years to come morphology as
mentioned will
always be a cornerstone of hematology
where do you see morphology in the next
10 years
and do you think various elements will
entirely become
automated or some aspects will have to
remain
manual
okay where are we going to go over the
next few years well
it's as a a very interesting great
question
because things are changing so rapidly
we have a number of platforms out there
that
will classify cells
for us and really increase the rate with
which we can review films
and it will reduce the number of films
that we have to look at
manually down the microscope some people
have often questioned does that mean
we're going to lose that skill
i don't think we will i think it will
allow us to add another skill
the for want of a better phrase the
electronic
morphology we will have to develop
skills
and get our eye and calibrate our eyes
for
looking at these all these images that
are produced
and deciding whether or not the cells
have been classified correctly
so we still do need people with that
knowledge
and experience and training to be able
to look at the results coming from these
automated systems
to say whether or not the cells have
been classified correctly
there are a number of
papers that have been written to show
that in cases of extreme
abnormality cells
are very difficult certain automated
platforms
find cells very difficult to classify
and that is when we have to take our
films
and look at them under the microscope
and apply
that subjectivity in order to say what's
actually going on
what are we looking at what are the
morphological features
so looking down a microscope will
always be a required skill
how much we look down the microscope
well that may change
and even though it may reduce we may
find ourselves looking at more digital
images on big screens
but still applying our knowledge
thank you dan okay your next question
do you know of a way to preserve stained
smears for a long time
well certainly in my laboratory we have
stain smears
that we have filed going back 30 years
and more
we as a matter of course will always
file away our peripheral blood smears
with our bone marrow smears and there's
a requirement for us to keep those
bone marrow smears for for a minimum of
30 years
we do store them upright in trays
in the dark and it's nothing more
complicated than that
we go back to them frequently and we
find that there's
no loss of color and they look
absolutely fine
we we have a what we call in my
laboratory the
green dot collection which goes back
um as a teaching set over 35 years
and some of those films having been
stored
in the dark just in normal ambient
temperature
in the laboratory have got as good a
morphology as the day that they were
spread
thank you it looks like we have time for
a few more questions
so this one's interesting i've noticed a
difference
staining adult versus newborn slides
the red cells especially should slides
from neonates be stained
differently
i that's a very that's quite a difficult
question to
to answer really because at the end of
the day
one has to follow one's local protocols
that have been agreed
by laboratory staff supervisors and the
clinical teams using that service
that's really the disclaimer answer to
that question
but we we have a large adult population
we have a very large neonatal and
pediatric population
and yes we do sometimes
see difference in staining and that's
sometimes due to
the hematocrits being slightly different
and a slightly thinner film will appear
slightly paler
and a slightly thicker film say a packed
film from a neonate
with a very high hemoglobin for example
may have a more vivid color so the red
cells
may appear more red the white cells
may appear more more pale
so there's a combination of colors of
course the amount of
protein in the plasma that obviously
gets
mixed with the whole blood when you're
making the slide can affect the way the
slides look
both macroscopically and microscopically
as well macroscopically they will appear
slightly more blue with a higher protein
concentration
microscopically you might see a more
sort of yellow blue appearance to the
background
between the cells but generally if
you've got a good
quality stain that you are quality
controlling every day against criteria
such as
those shown in one of the slides there
should be no need
to use a different approach to staining
pediatric neonatal films versus adult
films
okay dan let's go ahead and wrap up with
this last question
how did you validate your current
staining
our current staining well 90 of our
slides we
use an automated slide maker and stainer
we have a secondary method which is a
semi-automated method where we make the
slides by hand but then put them
through and they get stay fixed and
stained
by an automated method we
compared the two we knew that on our new
system
we had to have certain criteria set up
so we used a grade of one to five
and compared the stain quality from our
new system
versus the stain quality from our
existing system
with one being non-comparable and very
poor
and five being very comparable and
excellent staining
against criteria such as color of the
red cells
color of the white cells color of the
nuclei
appearance of granules and appearance of
cytoplasm
we also looked at other factors such as
the presence or absence of water
artifact
and the distribution of cells were there
gaps left between the cells was the
smearing quality
acceptable not just sustaining quality
we looked at a number of normal slides
20 slides
and we looked at a number of
abnormalities including those
conditions that present with blasts and
promyelocytes
and and other white cells and red cells
at different stages of maturation
so really we sat down and we thought
what do we want this new system to show
us and to what degree
of course it is subjective when you
grade those so we made sure
that we had at least two or three people
looking at these slides
and that there was consensus when
scoring on this system of one to five
that that's all that we could do but we
found that it worked for us
thank you dan and thank you to our
audience for their questions that
concludes our live q a session
now dan do you have any final comments
for our audience before we go today i
i think really yes morphology
is an art and it's a science we have to
know
what we're looking at but we have to
know why things
appear the way they do when we're
talking about morphology
and it's not something that someone can
be trained
and fully competent in in a case of just
a few weeks
or months we've been looking at
films for decades and decades
and every day we might see something new
and something that we have to go and
look up and something that surprises us
so it's always an ongoing process and as
far as morphology is concerned
one is never too old to learn
thank you again dan for your time today
and your important and informative
presentations
we would also like to thank labberts and
our sponsor abbott for underwriting
today's educational webcast
and before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their questions
as a reminder any questions that we did
not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed
on demand and labyrinths will alert you
via email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time take care
goodbye